[Music]
how do ideas become industries how do
inventions become innovations how do you
break through in this course on
problem-solving and new venture creation
you'll learn how entrepreneurs match
promising technologies with customer
needs to build successful businesses
you'll acquire new analytical skills as
you navigate the complexities of the
commercialization process moving a
technology from lab to the market
how will a technology be used is that
technology ready
how will funding be secured what is the
business model throughout this journey
you'll hear from a variety of experts
including founders funders and industry
mentors who will share their advice and
experiences related to bringing new
ideas to market many ideas never move
beyond the lab and those that do often
fail to achieve commercial viability how
do we successfully match seeds with
needs join us as we unlock the potential
of promising technologies and their
ability to solve some of our planet's
most urgent challenges
[Music]